- "양자 정보와 계산의 이해"에 다시 오신 걸
환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 다섯 번째 레슨이고, 양자 알고리즘에 대한
시리즈의 두 번째 유닛 첫 번째 레슨이에요.
이 유닛에서는 양자 정보의
계산적 이점을 살펴볼 거예요. 즉, 우리가 뭘 할 수 있는지
양자 컴퓨터로 할 수 있는 것과 양자 컴퓨터가 고전적인
컴퓨터에 비해 잠재적으로 가질 수 있는 이점을 알아볼 거예요.
분산 환경이 아니라 단일 양자 컴퓨터로 뭘 할 수 있는지에
집중할 거예요. 예를 들면,
여러 양자 컴퓨터가 어떤 종류의 네트워크를 통해 상호작용하는 환경 말고요.
사실 분산 환경에서도 양자 이점이 있긴 해요. 통신이나
암호학이 관련되는 경우인데,
이 유닛에서는 그런 것들에 대해
이야기하지 않을 거예요.
이 유닛은 단일 양자 컴퓨터에서 실행되는 양자 알고리즘에 관한 거예요.
자연스러운 질문부터 시작해 볼게요. 양자 컴퓨터가
잠재적으로 어떤 이점을 제공할 수 있을까요?
가장 큰 건 양자 컴퓨터가 일부 계산 문제에 대해 더 빠른 해결책을 제공할 수 있다는 거예요.
시간은 소중하고, 우리가 매일 사용하는 컴퓨터가
꽤 빠르긴 하지만, 여전히 너무 느려서
특정 계산 문제들은 풀 수가 없어요. 그 문제들의
본질적인 계산적 어려움 때문이에요.
양자 컴퓨터가 고전적인 컴퓨터로는 너무 느려서 풀 수 없는
문제들을 풀 수 있게 해줄 수 있다는 이 잠재력이
지난 수십 년간 양자 알고리즘
연구를 이끌어 온 원동력이에요.
시간 외에도 고려할 수 있는
다른 계산 자원들이 있어요. 예를 들어 계산에 필요한 컴퓨터 메모리 양 같은 거죠.
하지만 양자 컴퓨터는 메모리 측면에서는
그렇게 많은 절약을 제공하지 못해요. 알고 보면 그렇고, 고전적인 컴퓨터
메모리는 꽤 저렴하거든요.
특히 양자 메모리에 비하면요. 그래서 여기서는
그다지 전망이 밝지 않아요.
계산에 필요한 에너지 양 같은 다른 자원도 생각해 볼 수 있지만,
사실 고전적으로 계산하는 데는 에너지가 별로 필요 없어요.
특히 속도를 좀 늦춰도 괜찮다면요.
그래서 정말로 계산에 필요한 시간이
우리의 주된 관심사예요.
레슨 개요예요. 이 레슨은 쿼리 모델이라고 알려진
특정 계산 모델에 관한 거예요.
이 모델을 알고리즘 아이디어를 개발하기 위한 일종의 페트리 접시라고 생각하면 돼요. 양자든 고전적이든요.
실생활에서 마주치는 종류의 계산 문제를
설명하는 실용적인 모델은 아니에요.
이 유닛의 이후 레슨에서는 쿼리 모델에서 벗어나서 더 실용적인
계산 개념에 기반한 모델에 집중할 거예요.
하지만 쿼리 모델은 시작하기에
아주 좋은 곳이에요.
간단한 모델이라서 기술적 세부 사항에
방해받지 않고 양자 컴퓨터의 잠재력을 탐구할 수 있어요.
또한 양자 컴퓨팅의 정말 중요한 아이디어들과
그것이 어떻게 작동하는지를 분리해서 볼 수 있게 해줘요.
양자 컴퓨팅은 사실 이 모델 안에서 처음 발전했고,
그 안에서 개발된 아이디어들이 직접적으로
중요한 양자 알고리즘에 영감을 줬어요.
예를 들어 Shor의 인수분해 알고리즘 같은 거요.
레슨의 첫 번째 섹션에서는 쿼리 계산 모델이 구체적으로 무엇인지 살펴볼 거예요.
그리고 두 번째, 세 번째, 네 번째 섹션에서는
세 가지 양자 쿼리 알고리즘을 논의할 거예요. 바로 Deutsch의 알고리즘,
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘,
그리고 Simon의 알고리즘이에요. 이것들은 점점 더
인상적인 이점을 보여줘요.
쿼리 계산 모델 내에서 양자 컴퓨터가
고전적인 컴퓨터에 비해 갖는 이점을요.
쿼리 계산 모델을 설명하기 위해, 먼저 더 표준적인
계산 추상화부터 시작해 볼게요.
여기 아주 간단하고 기본적인 용어로
계산을 나타내는 그림이 있어요.
입력이 있는데, 보통 이진 문자열 형태를 취해요.
원한다면 다른 기호를 사용할 수도 있지만요.
입력은 계산에 제공되는데, 이 그림에서는
파란 직사각형으로 표현돼 있어요.
그리고 계산의 결과로 출력이 생성되는데,
역시 가장 일반적으로는 이진 문자열이에요.
물론 이 그림은 계산 자체가
어떻게 작동하는지 전혀 구체적이지 않아요.
이를 위해 다양한 구체적인 계산 모델을
만들 수 있어요. 튜링 머신이나 불리언 circuit 같은 거요.
또는 양자 계산을 생각한다면
양자 circuit도요.
이 그림이 우리가 매일 사용하는 많은 컴퓨터가
계속해서 입력을 받고 출력을 생성한다는 사실을
표현하지 못하는 건 맞아요.
기본적으로 우리나 다른 컴퓨터와 상호작용하는 거죠.
예를 들면 인터넷을 통해서요.
하지만 여기서 그런 상호작용을
표현하려는 건 아니에요.
이건 독립된 계산 작업을
모델링하는 거예요.
예를 들어 입력은 숫자의 이진 인코딩이거나
행렬의 표현일 수 있어요.
또는 분자의 설명이거나 정말 우리가 생각하는 무엇이든 될 수 있고, 어떤 계산 작업이
그 입력에 대해서만 수행되는 거예요.
여기서 핵심 포인트는 전체 입력이
계산에 제공되고, 입력에 대해 숨겨진 것이 아무것도 없다는 거예요.
쿼리 계산 모델은
다르게 작동해요.
쿼리 모델에서는 입력이 함수 형태로
제공되고, 계산이 쿼리를 통해 접근할 수 있어요.
다시 말해서, 함수를 다른 입력에 대해
평가함으로써요.
여기 그림 형태로
표현된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이전에 봤던 것과 비슷하게, 계산은 파란 직사각형으로
표현되지만, 입력을 직접 받는 대신
비트 문자열 같은 형태로 받는 게 아니라,
질문을 하고 답을 받는 방식으로 입력에 접근해요.
입력을 제공하는 메커니즘을 가리킬 때
오라클이나 블랙박스라는 용어를 사용하기도 해요.
복잡도 이론에서 오라클과 블랙박스 사이에
구별이 있긴 하지만, 이 논의에서는 전혀 관련이 없어요.
어쨌든 이 용어들은
기본적인 아이디어를 전달하려는 거예요.
고대 그리스에서는 오라클한테 갈 수 있었어요.
델피의 오라클 같은 곳에 가서 중요한 질문을 할 수 있었죠.
그러면 오라클은 그 특정 질문에
답해 줬지만, 자기가 아는 모든 걸 말해 주지는 않았어요.
비슷한 맥락에서, 블랙박스를 생각할 때,
우리가 염두에 두는 건 어떤 종류의 프로세스나 시스템인데
뭘 넣을지 선택할 수 있고 뭐가 나오는지 볼 수 있지만,
내부 작동 방식은 이해하지 못하는 거예요.
여기서도 마찬가지예요. 문제의 입력은 함수 형태를
취하고, 우리가 할 수 있는 건 그 함수를 평가하는 것뿐이에요.
그 외에는 그것이 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한
지식이나 이해가 없어요.
이 레슨 전체에서 입력을 나타내는
함수에 대해 문자 f를 사용할 거고, 다음과 같은 가정을 할 거예요.
항상 여기 보이는
형태를 취한다고요.
시그마는 이진 알파벳을 나타내니까, f는 비트 문자열에서
비트 문자열로의 함수예요.
구체적으로, f의 입력은 길이 n의
비트 문자열이고, 출력은 길이 m의 비트 문자열이라고 가정할 거예요.
여기서 n과 m은 양의 정수예요.
다른 문제에 따라 n과 m에 제약이
있겠지만, 모든 경우에 입력 함수는 이런 형태를 취할 거예요.
계산이 쿼리를 한다고 할 때,
의미하는 건 함수 f가 한 번 평가된다는 거예요.
즉, 길이 N의 어떤 문자열 x가 계산에 의해 선택되고,
문자열 f(x)가 오라클이나 블랙박스에 의해 제공되는 거예요.
그리고 마지막으로, 쿼리 알고리즘의 계산 비용을 측정하는
아주 간단한 방법은
필요한 쿼리 수를 세는 거예요.
계산이 얼마나 오래 걸리는지에 가장
관심이 있는 건 사실이지만, 쿼리 모델을 연구할 때는
보통 간단하게 쿼리만 세요.
이 레슨에서도 그렇게 할 거예요.
자, 이제 쿼리 문제의 몇 가지 예를 살펴볼게요.
쿼리 모델에서의 계산 문제를 말하는 거예요.
참고로 여기서는 문제 자체만 설명할 거고,
이 시점에서는 어떻게 푸는지에 대해서는 아무 말도 안 할 거예요.
첫 번째 문제는 OR 문제예요.
이 경우 입력은 n비트에서 1비트로의
함수예요. 이 문제에서 m은 1이에요.
그리고 이 문제의 필요한
출력은 1 아니면 0이에요.
어떤 n비트 문자열 x에 대해 f(x)가 1이면, 정답은 1이에요.
그렇지 않고 모든 문자열 x에 대해
f(x)가 항상 0이면, 정답은 0이에요.
함수 f가 2의 n승 비트에 대한 랜덤 접근을
제공한다고 생각하면, 각 n비트 문자열 x에 대해 하나씩이고,
문제가 요구하는 건 그 비트들의 OR이에요.
그래서 OR 문제라고 불리는 거예요.
또 다른 예는 패리티 문제인데, OR 문제와 비슷하지만 패리티를 구하는 거예요.
다른 말로 하면, 함수의 모든 단일 비트
출력 값의 배타적 OR을 구하는 거예요.
다른 방식으로 말하면, f(x)가 1인
n비트 문자열 x의 수가 짝수이면 정답은 0이에요.
그리고 그 수가 홀수이면
정답은 1이에요.
m이 반드시 1이 아닌 문제의 예는 최솟값 문제예요.
여기서 함수 f는 보통 형태를 취하고, n과 m에 대한 제약은 없어요.
그리고 정답은 함수의 출력 값 중에서
사전식 순서에서 가장 먼저 오는 거예요.
또는 길이 m의 문자열을 이진 표기법으로
음이 아닌 정수를 나타내는 것으로 생각하면,
정답은 이 함수에서 나오는 가능한 값 중
가장 작은 또는 최솟값이에요.
때로는 입력 함수에 대한 프로미스, 다시 말해서
어떤 종류의 보장이 있는 쿼리 문제도 고려해요.
그 프로미스를 충족하지 않는 함수에 대해서는 걱정하지 않아요.
프로미스를 만족하지 않는 함수들은 "상관없는" 입력으로 간주돼요.
그런 입력에서 무슨 일이 일어나든 우리 책임이 아니에요.
프로미스가 있는 쿼리 문제의 예로 유니크 서치가 있어요.
OR 문제와 관련이 있지만
다른 문제예요.
입력 함수는 OR 문제와 같은 형태예요.
n비트 문자열을 비트로 매핑하는 거예요.
이번에는 f를 1로 평가하게 만드는
문자열 Z가 정확히 하나 있다는 게 보장돼요.
z 외의 모든 문자열 x에 대해
f(x)는 0이고, 정확한 출력은 이 유일한 문자열 z예요.
물론 이 조건을 만족하지 않는 함수 f의 선택도 있지만,
이런 함수가 입력으로 주어졌을 때
이 문제의 알고리즘에 대해
어떤 요구사항도 두지 않아요.
프로미스를 만족하는 함수에 대해서만 신경 써요.
자, 방금 언급한 네 가지 문제는 모두
꽤 자연스러운 문제예요. 설명하기 쉽고,
그걸 풀어야 할 필요가 생기는 상황을 쉽게 상상할 수 있죠.
하지만 어떤 쿼리 문제들은 전혀 그렇지 않아요.
사실 때로는 매우 인위적인 쿼리 문제를
고려하는데, 누군가 실제로 풀고 싶어할 상황을 상상하기 어려운 거예요.
Simon의 문제는 이 레슨 뒤에서 볼 건데,
어느 정도 이 범주에 속하지만, 다른 것들 중에는
어떤 의미에서 훨씬 더 심한 것도 있어요. 하지만 그것들이 쿼리 모델 연구에 꽤 중요한 것으로 밝혀져요.
이런 문제들을 반드시 실제로 풀고 싶어서
연구하는 건 아니에요.
이렇게 생각하면 돼요. 다양한 종류의
극단을 찾고 있는 거예요.
특히 이 페트리 접시 같은 모델 안에서 작업할 때,
양자 알고리즘적 아이디어를 탐구하는 자연스러운 방법은
양자 컴퓨터의 힘을 가장 잘 활용할 수 있는
매우 인위적인 문제를 만들어 보는 거예요.
이것이 실제로 양자 컴퓨터가 더 실용적인 환경에서
어떻게 유용할 수 있는지에 대해 많은 것을 알려줄 수 있어요.
어떤 계산 모델에서 작업하느냐에 따라
쿼리의 개념을 다른 방식으로 형식화할 수 있어요.
예를 들어 튜링 머신 계산 모델에서는,
이 시리즈에서 다루지는 않을 건데,
그 모델에 맞는 쿼리의 개념을
형식화하는 특정 방법이 있어요.
circuit 모델에서는 query gate라고 불리는
특별한 종류의 gate를 정의하고, 그게 쿼리가 형식적으로 표현되는 방식이에요.
불리언 circuit에서는 이걸 하는 아주 간단한 방법이 있는데,
query gate가 있다고 상상하는 거예요.
입력 함수를 직접 평가하는 거예요. 화면에서 보이는 것처럼요.
아이디어는 이 query gate를 사용해서
우리가 보고 있는 문제를 풀 수 있는 circuit을 만드는 거예요.
제대로 작동하려면, circuit은 어떤 입력 함수 f가 주어지든 올바른 답을 내야 해요.
프로미스 문제의 경우에는 프로미스를 충족한다고 가정하고요.
여기 n이 1일 때 패리티 문제를 푸는
불리언 circuit의 간단한 예가 있어요.
그래서 입력 함수 f는 이 경우에
1비트에서 1비트로의 함수예요.
이 circuit이 하는 건 두 개의 query gate를 사용해서
입력 0과 1에 대해 함수 f를 평가하는 거예요.
그런 다음 query gate에서 얻은 두 출력 값을
레슨 3에서 봤던 XOR을 계산하는 불리언 circuit에 넣는 거예요.
XOR은 패리티와 같은 거예요.
분명히 해두면, 이 두 입력 값은
문제, 즉 패리티 문제에 대한 입력이 아니에요.
쿼리 모델에서 작업할 때 문제에 대한 입력은
함수 f이고, 이 두 circuit 입력은
하드코딩된 값으로 생각해야 해요.
절대 변하지 않고, 본질적으로 알고리즘의 일부예요.
f(0)과 f(1)의 XOR을 계산하고 싶으니까,
이 두 와이어를 이렇게 초기화해서
작동하게 만든 거예요. 여기서 query gate를
두 개 사용했어요. 이것과 이것.
그래서 이 불리언 circuit이 나타내는 알고리즘은
두 번의 쿼리를 하는 거고, 잠시 1비트에서
1비트로의 함수에 대한 패리티 문제를 생각해 보면,
이 문제를 푸는 어떤 불리언 circuit이든
최소 두 번의 쿼리를 해야 한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
쿼리를 한 번만 하면 함수 f의 출력 값 하나만 알고
나머지는 모르니까, 패리티에 대한 정보가 전혀 없어요.
다른 출력 값이 0이 될 수도 1이 될 수도 있으니까,
문제의 두 가지 가능한 답 중 어느 것이든 될 수 있거든요.
그래서 쿼리 수 측면에서 이 불리언 circuit은
최선이에요.
n이 1일 때 패리티 문제에 대해서요.
넘어가기 전에 query gate에 대해 한 가지 더 언급할 만한 게 있는데, 쿼리 알고리즘을 설계하고 분석할 때
query gate가 어떻게 구현되는지는
전혀 걱정하지 않는다는 거예요.
이 query gate는 우리에게 주어진 것으로 가정하고,
그걸 만드는 어려움은 우리 관심사가 아니에요.
query gate 자체를 원한다면 입력이라고 생각해도 되고,
입력을 만드는 건 우리 일이 아니에요. 그냥 주어진 입력으로
특정 문제를 풀려는 거예요.
물론 f가 1비트에서 1비트로의 함수일 때는
가능한 선택이 네 가지뿐이고,
어떤 것이든 구현하기 충분히 쉬울 거예요.
하지만 일반적으로 입력 비트가 많은 함수의 경우,
그 함수들에 대한 query gate를
구현하기가 극도로 어려울 수 있어요.
분명히 해두면, query gate가 어떻게
구현되는지의 문제가 중요하지 않다는 게 아니라,
쿼리 알고리즘의 비용의
일부로 고려되지 않는다는 거예요.
이건 이것이 실용적 컴퓨팅이나 실제로 circuit을 만드는 것에 대한 게 아니라는 아이디어와 일치해요.
계산에 대해 흥미로운 것들을 알려주는
이론적 프레임워크 안에서 작업하는 거예요.
이 모델에서 더 표준적인 계산 모델로 넘어갈 때 이것에 대해 더 할 말이 있을 거예요. 그게 주로 다음 레슨,
레슨 6의 내용이에요.
이제 양자 circuit에 대해
관심을 돌려 볼게요.
양자 circuit에서는 query gate의 정의를
유니터리하게 바꿀 거예요.
양자 circuit 안에서 쿼리를 할 수 있고
양자 상태에 대해 선형적으로 작동하길 원해요.
그래야 효과적으로
중첩 상태에서 쿼리를 할 수 있으니까요.
불리언 circuit에서 봤던 것과 비교해서
쿼리의 의미를 바꾸는 게 골대를 옮기는 것처럼 보일 수 있지만,
다음 레슨에서 더 자세히 논의할
정당한 이유가 있어요.
지금은 그냥 정의일 뿐이에요.
구체적으로, 정의는 다음과 같아요.
이전과 같은 형태의 함수 f가 주어졌을 때,
n비트 문자열을 m비트 문자열로 매핑하는 거예요.
query gate Uf는 n + m개의 qubit에 작용하고
여기 설명된 표준 기저 상태에 대한
작용으로 정의돼요.
이 정의를 나타내는 그림을 곧 볼 건데,
먼저 여기서 사용되는 표기법을 명확히 할게요.
같은 길이의 두 문자열 사이의 연산으로
XOR 기호를 사용할 때마다,
비트별 배타적 OR을 가리키는 거예요.
여기 예를 볼 수 있어요.
정의에서 y와 f(x) 모두 길이 m의
문자열이니까, 여기 이 문자열은
그 두 문자열을 한 비트씩
XOR해서 얻는 문자열을 나타내요. 그리고 여기 이 gate가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하는 다이어그램이에요.
위쪽 n개의 qubit는
함수의 인자에 해당해요.
표준 기저 상태, 이 다이어그램에서 ket x로 시작할 때,
그 표준 기저 상태는 변하지 않고 통과해서
출력의 일부로 그대로 나와요.
아래쪽 m개의 qubit는 함수 f의 출력에
해당하고, 어떤 표준 기저 상태에서 시작할 때,
이 다이어그램에서 ket y일 때, 함수의 출력
f(x)가 문자열 y에 XOR돼요.
이건 표준 기저 상태에서 일어나는 거고,
다른 양자 상태에서 일반적으로 뭐가 일어나는지 알고 싶으면
항상 그렇듯 선형성을 사용해요.
query gate를 이렇게 정의하는 이유, 즉 입력을 그대로 내보내고 출력에 비트별 XOR을 사용하는 이유는
이 gate가 함수 f의 어떤 선택에 대해서도 항상 유니터리하기 때문이에요.
이건 사실
결정론적 연산이에요.
함수 F의 어떤 선택에 대해 이걸 행렬로 표현하면, 순열 행렬을 얻게 돼요.
각 행과 각 열에 1이 하나씩 있고, 나머지 항목은 모두 0인 거예요.
그리고 순열 행렬은
항상 유니터리예요.
사실 이 연산의 경우, 연산이 자기 자신의
역이에요. 그래서 Uf 대거는 Uf와 같아요.
이 gate로 하고 싶은 게 어떤 문자열 x에 대해
f(x)를 평가하는 것뿐이라면 쉬워요.
y를 전부 0인 문자열로 설정하면 돼요.
그러면 비트별 XOR을 하면 f(x)만 남아요.
참고로 여기서 전부 0인 문자열을 나타내는 표기법을 볼 수 있어요.
0의 M승처럼 보이지만, 그런 뜻이 아니에요.
길이가 M인 0의 문자열을
의미하는 거예요.
문자열에 대해 이야기할 때 숫자가 아니라,
지수는 보통 그 문자열을 몇 번 반복한다는 뜻이에요.
그래서 이건 0을 m번 반복한 거예요.
이 문자열을 편리하고 정확하게 설명하는 방법일 뿐이에요.
다시 한번 말하지만, 쿼리 모델에서 작업할 때
이 query gate를 어떻게 구현하는지는 걱정하지 않아요.
불리언 circuit의 query gate에서도
같은 문제가 있었어요.
입력을 준비하는 건 우리 일이 아니에요.
이 query gate 형태로 입력이 주어지는 거예요.
다만 한 가지 지적할 건, 불리언 circuit을 사용해서
함수 f를 구현하는 방법을 안다면, 그 구현을
Uf의 양자 circuit 구현으로 꽤 직접적으로
변환하는 게 가능하고, 다음 레슨에서 그 방법을 정확히 볼 거예요.
참고로, 함수 f에 대한 단일 고전적 query gate를 사용해서
이런 식으로 작동하는 불리언 circuit을 만드는 건 꽤 간단해요.
하지만 그건 이 유니터리 gate의
양자 circuit 구현과는 상당히 달라요.
하지만 핵심은, 고전적 쿼리 알고리즘에서
이렇게 작동하는 query gate를 갖는 것은 사실
f에 대한 일반적인 고전적 query gate를 갖는 것과
동등하다는 거예요. 둘 중 하나를 사용해서 다른 하나를 구현할 수 있다는 의미에서요.
이 레슨의 이 섹션에서는 Deutsch의 알고리즘을 논의할 건데,
아주 간단한 양자 쿼리 알고리즘이지만 정말 보석 같아요.
이 알고리즘은 David Deutsch의 1985년 논문에서 나왔어요. 양자 컴퓨팅의 이론적 기초에 대해 작업한 최초의 사람 중 하나였죠.
알고리즘 자체는 Deutsch의 1985년 논문의
아주 작은 부분이고, 사실
지금 Deutsch의 알고리즘이라 부르는 건
Deutsch가 설명한 알고리즘의 개선된 버전이에요.
양자 컴퓨터가 계산적 이점을 제공할 수 있는 매우 소박한
예를 보여주지만, 어딘가에서 시작해야 하잖아요.
그리고 이건 정말로 일을 시작하게 만든 중요한 불꽃이었어요.
Deutsch의 알고리즘은 양자 컴퓨팅 맥락에서 흔히 Deutsch의 문제라고 불리는 쿼리 문제를 풀어요.
하지만 사실 이건 우리가 이미 이야기했던
1비트에서 1비트로의 함수에 대한 패리티 문제에 다름 아니에요.
이미 봤듯이 1비트에서 1비트로의 함수는 네 가지가 있고,
화면에 값의 표로 설명돼 있어요.
이 함수들 중 첫 번째와 마지막은 상수이고,
가운데 두 개는 균형 잡힌 거예요. 두 가지 가능한 출력 값이
같은 횟수로 나타난다는 의미에서요.
두 상수 함수의 경우, 패리티,
다시 말해서 두 출력의 배타적 OR은 0이에요.
그리고 두 균형 잡힌 함수의 경우, 출력의 패리티는 1이에요.
그래서 이 특정 경우, 즉 함수 f가
단일 비트를 입력으로 받는 경우에
패리티 문제를 동등하게 설명하는 방법은, 다른 말로 Deutsch의 문제는, 여기 보이는 것과 같아요.
입력은 1비트에서 1비트로의 함수 f이고,
f가 상수이면 출력은 0이고
f가 균형 잡혀 있으면 1이에요.
이미 말했듯이, 이 문제를 푸는 모든 고전적 쿼리 알고리즘은
f에 최소 두 번의 쿼리를 해야 해요.
f의 두 출력 값 중 하나만 알면,
두 출력의 패리티에 대한 정보가 전혀 없어요.
참고로 이건 무작위성을 사용하는
고전적 알고리즘에서도 마찬가지예요.
무작위성은 때때로 쿼리 문제를 푸는 데 매우 유용할 수 있고,
레슨 뒤에서 예를 볼 거예요.
하지만 여기서는 무작위성이 도움이 안 돼요.
그래서 이전의 알고리즘은 Deutsch의 문제에 대한
고전적 쿼리 알고리즘 중에서 최적이에요.
이제 Deutsch의 알고리즘을 볼 건데, 단일 쿼리로
Deutsch의 문제를 푸는 양자 쿼리 알고리즘이에요.
그리고 여기 양자 circuit으로
설명된 알고리즘이에요.
여기 보이는 것처럼 초기화된 두 개의 qubit가 있어요.
위쪽은 ket 0으로, 아래쪽은 ket 1로 초기화돼요.
왜 이렇게 qubit을 초기화하는지는 곧 볼 거예요.
두 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 수행하고,
query gate에 넣고, 위쪽 qubit에 또 다른 Hadamard gate를 수행하고,
그런 다음 측정해요. 그리고 측정 결과가
확실하게 문제의 정확한 답을 준다는 게 주장이에요.
그러면 circuit을 한 단계씩 분석해서
정확히 어떻게 작동하는지 볼게요.
첫 번째 Hadamard gate 층 이후 두 qubit의 상태는
마이너스 상태와 플러스 상태의 텐서 곱이에요.
위쪽의 Hadamard는 0 상태를 플러스 상태로 매핑하고,
아래쪽의 Hadamard는 1 상태를 마이너스 상태로 매핑해요.
위쪽 qubit이 오른쪽에 있고 아래쪽 qubit이 왼쪽에 있으니까, 이게 우리가 얻는 상태예요.
아래쪽 qubit이 마이너스 상태인 게 매우 중요해요. 참고로 아래쪽 qubit을
1 상태가 아닌 0 상태로 초기화하면 이게 작동하지 않아요.
이 상태를 여기 보이는 것처럼
반쯤 전개할 거예요.
그렇게 하는 이유가 지금은 명확하지 않지만,
곧 편리해질 거예요.
다음으로, query gate가 수행된 후
두 qubit의 상태에 대해 생각해 볼게요.
query gate가 작동하는 방식은 위쪽 qubit의 표준 기저 상태에 대해
F를 계산하고 그 값을 아래쪽 qubit에 XOR하는 거예요.
그리고 여기서 그 결과를
볼 수 있어요.
첫 번째 항에서 위쪽 qubit의 표준 기저 상태는
0이니까, f(0)이 아래쪽 qubit에 XOR돼요.
그건 선형성으로 작동해요. 두 번째 항도 비슷한데, 위쪽 qubit의 표준 기저 상태가
1이니까, f(1)을 아래쪽 qubit에 XOR해요.
이 시점에서, 여기 아래 보이는 공식을 관찰하면
이 식을 단순화할 수 있어요. a가 0 또는 1일 때 작동하는 거예요.
그 두 값에 대해 따로따로 확인하면 돼요.
a가 0이면 a로 XOR해도 아무것도 안 변하고,
(-1)의 0승은 1이니까,
양변이 같아요. a가 1이면 XOR하면
ket 1 빼기 ket 0을 얻는데,
그건 -1 곱하기 ket 0 빼기
ket 1이에요.
그 공식을 사용해서 상태를 단순화하면,
왼쪽에서 a = f(0)이고 오른쪽에서 a = f(1)로 놓으면,
여기 보이는 식을
얻게 돼요.
두 양자 상태 벡터 π1과 π2를 비교하면,
Uf gate가 하는 건
효과적으로 두 값 f(0) 또는 f(1) 중 하나를
-1의 지수에, 다시 말해서
각 항의 위상에
넣는 거예요.
이게 아래쪽 qubit을 1로 초기화하고
Hadamard gate를 수행해서 마이너스 상태를 만드는 이유예요. 이것이 이걸 가능하게 해요.
이걸 위상 킥백 현상이라고 부르는데, 잠시 후에 다시 돌아와서 다른 각도에서 살펴볼 거예요.
꽤 중요하고, 이 레슨에서 몇 번 더 볼 거예요.
이후 레슨에서도요.
이제 마이너스 상태를 다시 밖으로 빼내서
여기 보이는 식을 얻을 수 있어요.
참고로, 여기서 실제로 얽힘이 전혀 없다는 걸
알아차리는 건 좀 흥미로워요.
이 상태들은 둘 다 곱 상태예요.
그래서, 뭐, 얽힘은 매우 흥미롭지만,
이 특정 알고리즘에서는 전혀
아무 역할도 하지 않아요.
좀 더 공간을 확보하기 위해 정리해 볼게요.
이제 할 수 있는 건 (-1)의 f(0)승을
밖으로 빼내서
여기 보이는 상태 식을
얻는 거예요.
여기서 -1의 지수에 f(0)과 f(1)의 배타적 OR이 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
(-1)의 f(0)승을 밖으로 빼냈으니까
f(1) 빼기 f(0)이 될 거라고 예상할 수 있지만,
XOR을 해도 같은 값을 얻어요. 이것들이 비트이고,
-1의 지수에 정수가 있을 때
중요한 건 그 정수가 짝수인지 홀수인지뿐이니까요.
이 상태를 표현하는 또 다른 방법은 여기 있는 것처럼,
XOR의 두 가지 가능한 경우를 고려하는 거예요.
그리고 이건 마지막 Hadamard gate의 작용과
측정을 고려할 때 상태를 표현하기 편리한 방법이에요.
위쪽 qubit에 마지막 Hadamard gate를 수행하면,
플러스 상태는 0 상태로 변환되고
마이너스 상태는 1 상태로 변환돼요.
이걸 더 간결하게 이렇게 쓸 수 있어요.
그리고 마지막으로 측정이 수행되면,
얻는 결과는 f(0)과 f(1)의 XOR이에요.
그게 우리가 찾는 값이고, Deutsch의 알고리즘은 이렇게 작동해요.
꽤 간단하고, 이게 어떻게 작동하는지,
단일 쿼리로 두 비트의 패리티를 계산할 수 있게 해주는 게 뭔지 자문하면,
두 번이 아닌 하나의 쿼리로,
합리적인 답은 간섭이에요.
효과적으로 f(0)과 f(1)을 동시에 계산하고 있어요.
먼저 위쪽 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 수행해서
f의 입력을 0과 1의 중첩 상태로 만들었으니까요.
그리고 위상 킥백과 마지막 Hadamard gate를 통해,
본질적으로 정답에 대한 보강 간섭과
오답에 대한 상쇄 간섭을 만들고 있는 거예요.
그래서 오답은 보이지 않고, 정답만 보이는 거예요.
위상 킥백 현상에 대해 약간 다른 각도에서
좀 더 이야기해 볼게요.
먼저 이 아주 간단한 공식을 관찰해 볼게요.
b와 c는 임의의 이진 값이에요.
간단히 말해서, 비트 b를 1로 XOR하는 건 b에 NOT gate 또는 x 연산을 수행하는 것과 같고,
물론 비트 b를 0으로 XOR하면
아무것도 안 하는데, 이건 항등 연산을 수행하는 것과 같아요.
그리고 항등 연산을 x의 0승으로 표현할 수 있어요.
그래서 표준 기저 상태 ket b 텐서 ket a인 두 qubit에
Uf gate를 수행하면,
이 결과를 얻어요. Uf gate의 정의에 의해서요.
그리고 그 공식을 사용하면, 여기 보이는 것처럼 그 상태를 다르게 쓸 수 있어요.
이 공식은 b의 모든 선택에 대해 작동하니까, 선형성에 의해 임의의 상태 SI에 대해서도
ket b 대신 작동해요.
특히, 원한다면 SI를 마이너스 상태로 선택할 수 있어요.
그리고 여기서 위상 킥백
현상이 일어나는 핵심이에요.
마이너스 상태에 x 연산을 적용하면
-1 곱하기 마이너스 상태를 얻기 때문이에요.
수학적 용어로 마이너스 상태는
x 연산의 고유벡터이고, 고유값은 -1이라고 해요.
고유벡터와 고유값은 선형대수학뿐만 아니라
양자 정보에서도 매우 중요하고,
이것들에 대해 훨씬 더 많은 이야기를 할 거예요.
시리즈가 계속되면서요.
하지만 지금은 이 간단한
공식만 있으면 돼요.
그걸 사용해서 우리의
상태 벡터를 단순화할 수 있어요.
바로 그게 본질적으로 위상 킥백 현상을
공식으로 쓴 거예요.
마이너스 상태가 NOT 연산의 고유벡터이고
고유값이 -1이기 때문에 작동하는 거예요.
레슨 7에서 이걸 꽤 큰 규모로 일반화할 거예요.
위상 추정 절차를 다룰 때인데,
Shor의 인수분해 알고리즘을 구동하는 거예요.
Deutsch의 알고리즘 분석에서 이 공식이
작동하는 걸 다음과 같이 볼 수 있어요.
query gate 이전에 우리 상태는 마이너스 상태와 플러스 상태의 텐서 곱이에요.
그런 다음 query gate를 적용하고,
플러스 상태를 전개하면 이 상태를 얻어요.
이제 위상 킥백 공식을 적용해서 이 식을 얻고,
그 다음 분석은 이전과 같이 진행돼요.
이전과 같지만, 여기서는 위상 킥백에
초점을 맞추고 있어요. 그래야 인식할 수 있고
다시 나왔을 때
준비가 되니까요.
다음으로 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘으로 넘어갈 건데,
Deutsch의 알고리즘의 확장으로 실제로 몇 가지 다른
쿼리 문제를 풀어요.
Deutsch의 알고리즘이 고전적 알고리즘에 비해
제공하는 이점은 꽤 소박해요. 한 번의 쿼리 대 두 번이니까요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘은 그 이점을 어느 정도 증가시키는데,
거기 도달하면 그게 무슨 뜻인지 설명할게요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘은 Deutsch의 알고리즘을 자연스럽고 직접적으로 확장한 것으로 볼 수 있어요.
1비트에서 1비트로의 함수에서 n비트에서 1비트로의 함수로, 다시 말해서 이런 형태의 함수로요.
양자 circuit으로 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘은
이렇게 생겼어요. 이걸 Deutsch-Jozsa circuit이라고 부를 건데
이 circuit과 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘 자체 사이에
약간의 구별을 두기 위해서예요. 고전적 후처리 단계도 있거든요.
아이디어는 이 circuit을 실행하고 측정하면
어떤 n비트 문자열 y를 얻는다는 거예요.
그게 함수 f에 대해
뭔가를 알려줘요.
참고로 이 시점에서 이 circuit으로 풀기를 희망할 수 있는
쿼리 문제가 뭔지 아직 말하지 않았어요. 곧 나올 거예요.
하지만 핵심은 이 circuit을 실행함으로써 f에 대한
정보를 얻을 수 있고, 그게 잠재적으로 쿼리 문제를 푸는 데 도움이 될 수 있다는 거예요.
f가 입력인 경우에요. 그리고 방금 말했듯이,
실제로 이 circuit을 사용해서
몇 가지 다른 쿼리 문제를
풀 수 있어요.
먼저 Deutsch-Jozsa 문제로 알려진 쿼리 문제를
살펴볼게요. Deutsch-Jozsa circuit이
원래 풀기 위해 만들어진 문제예요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 문제는 Deutsch의 문제의 일반화인데, 주어진 함수가 상수인지 균형 잡힌 건지 결정하는 게 목표예요.
이건 패리티 문제를 이런 형태의 함수로
일반화하는 자연스러운 방법이 아니라는 걸 주목하세요.
여기서 패리티를 계산하는 게 아니에요. 과제는
함수 f가 상수이면 0을 출력하고
함수 f가 균형 잡혀 있으면 1을 출력하는 거예요.
이 문제에서 먼저 주목할 건,
함수 f의 입력 비트 수 n이 최소 2일 때,
상수도 균형 잡힌 것도 아닌 함수가 존재한다는 거예요.
예를 들어 여기 상수도 균형 잡힌 것도 아닌
2비트에서 1비트로의 함수가 있어요.
두 이진 값이 모두 출력에 나타나니까 상수가 아니고,
두 출력 값이 다른 빈도로 나타나니까
균형 잡힌 것도 아니에요. 0은 세 번 나타나고
1은 한 번만 나타나요.
균형 잡히려면 출력 0과 1이
정확히 같은 횟수로 나타나야 해요.
n이 최소 2일 때 상수도 균형 잡힌 것도 아닌 함수가 있다는 건 괜찮아요. 그런 함수는
"상관없는" 입력으로 취급할 거예요.
다시 말해서 이건 프로미스 문제예요.
그리고 여기 문제의
정확한 진술이에요.
입력 함수 f가 상수이거나 균형 잡혀 있다는 게 보장되고,
목표는 어느 쪽인지 알아내는 거예요.
입력이 프로미스를 충족하지 않으면
무슨 일이 일어나든 우리 책임이 아니에요.
이 문제를 푸는 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘은,
먼저 Deutsch-Jozsa circuit을 실행하고 나서 0을 출력해요.
측정에서 얻은 문자열이
전부 0인 문자열이면 0을 출력하고, 그렇지 않으면 1을 출력해요.
다른 방식으로 말하면, 측정한 비트들의 OR을
출력하는 거예요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘을 분석하기 위해,
먼저 잠시 Hadamard gate에 대해 생각해 보는 게 도움이 될 거예요.
물론 Hadamard 연산을 행렬로 설명할 수 있지만,
표준 기저 상태에 대한 작용으로도
설명할 수 있어요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요.
이 두 방정식을 하나의 방정식으로 합칠 수 있는데,
a가 두 이진 값 중 어느 것이든 Hadamard 연산이
어떻게 작동하는지 설명해요.
그리고 조금 더 나아가서 얻는 것을
이런 합으로 표현할 수 있어요.
그 공식을 사용해서, Hadamard gate 층이 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하는
공식을 만들 수 있어요. n개의 qubit 각각에 하나의 Hadamard gate를 적용하는 거예요.
여기서 이 작용을
표준 기저 상태에 대해 설명하고 있어요.
표기법을 명확히 하면, H 텐서 n이라고 쓸 때, 텐서 n 부분이 위첨자인 건,
H의 n겹 텐서 곱, 다시 말해서
H의 n개 복사본을 전부 텐서 곱한 거예요.
이 연산을 표준 기저 상태에 적용하는 건데,
여기서 Qiskit이 사용하는 규칙을 따르고 있어요.
이진 문자열을 인덱싱하는 건데,
그 규칙을 소개하기 좋은 시점이니까요.
x0은 비트이고, x1도 비트이고, 이런 식으로
총 n개의 비트가 있고, 비트 순서는 화면에서 보이는 것처럼이에요.
이런 비트 인덱싱 방식은 문자열을 정수로 볼 때
비트의 유의성에 해당하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
예를 들어 이진 표기법에서요.
이 qubit들 각각에 Hadamard gate를 적용하면,
결과를 n겹 텐서 곱으로 다르게 표현할 수 있어요.
각 qubit에 적용된 Hadamard gate의 n겹 텐서 곱이고, 텐서 인수 각각에 공식을 적용할 수 있어요.
여기서 공식의 b 대신에
y와 -1부터 y1까지의 이름을 사용하고 있어요.
이것들은 이진 값이에요. 그리고 공식을 사용할 때마다 새 이름을 쓰도록 하고 있어요.
그런 다음 텐서 곱의 다중선형성을 사용해서
모든 걸 전개하면 여기 보이는 식을 얻어요.
명확히 하면, n개의 합이 하나의 합으로 합쳐지지만,
여전히 개별 이진 값의 모든 가능한 값에 대해
합산하고 있어요.
이제 좀 더 나아갈 수 있도록 정리해 볼게요.
다음 단계는 이진 내적이라는
문자열에 대한 새 연산을 도입하는 거예요.
이건 같은 길이의 이진 문자열에 대한 연산이에요.
같은 길이의 두 문자열 x와 y의 이진 내적은,
개별 비트들의 곱의 배타적 OR, 즉 패리티예요.
개별 비트들의 곱의 패리티요.
개별 비트의 논리적 AND의 XOR이라고 할 수도 있어요. AND는 이진 값에 대해
곱과 같으니까요.
또 다른 설명 방법은, 개별 비트들의 곱의 합이
홀수인지 짝수인지에 따라
1 또는 0이라는 거예요.
문자열을 이진 값의 벡터로 생각하면 내적과 매우 비슷한데,
모듈로 2로 계산하는 거예요.
다시 말해서 2로 나눈 나머지를 취하는 거예요.
하지만 진짜 내적은 아니니까 다른 이름이 필요해요.
지금 다루는 경우에서, 이진 내적을 사용해서
Hadamard gate 층의 작용에 대한 공식을
표준 기저 상태에 대해 더 간결하게 만들 수 있어요. 여기 있어요.
여기 이 합이 -1의 지수에
나타나기 때문에
중요한 건 짝수인지 홀수인지뿐이라는 사실을
사용하고 있어요. 그 외에는 기본적으로 공식의 축약 버전이에요.
참고로 이진 내적은 대칭적이에요.
x 점 y와 y 점 x가 같다는 의미에서요.
그래서 유용할 때마다
순서를 자유롭게 바꿀 수 있어요.
이제 그 공식이 있으니까,
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit을 분석하는 건 꽤 쉬울 거예요.
n개의 qubit을 0 상태로, 아래쪽 qubit을 1 상태로 시작하고,
모두에 Hadamard gate를 수행해요.
그래서 이게 우리가 얻는
n + 1개 qubit의 상태예요.
아래쪽 qubit을 따로 다루는 건
그게 편리하기 때문이에요.
그리고 다시, 위상 킥백
현상이 일어나는 걸 볼 거예요.
공식을 사용해서 이 식을 얻을 수 있는데,
전부 0인 문자열을 x에, x를 y에 대입하면 돼요.
전부 0인 문자열과 어떤 문자열의
이진 내적은 0이라는 걸 참고하면요.
하지만 이걸 직접 추론할 수도 있어요. n개의 플러스 상태의
텐서 곱을 취하면 이걸 얻고,
마이너스 상태와 텐서 곱해요. 그런 다음 UF gate가 적용되고,
여기서 위상 킥백 현상이 일어나요.
합에서 각 x에 대해 f(x) 값이
마이너스 상태에 XOR돼요.
그래서 f(x)가 위상에 킥백돼요.
이제 위쪽 n개의 qubit에만 Hadamard gate의
또 다른 층을 적용하는데, 이번에는 정말로 공식이 필요해요.
적용하고 약간의 단순화를 하면
여기 이 상태를 얻어요.
그래서 그게 측정 직전의
최종 상태예요.
상태가 약간 복잡해 보이고, 함수 f에 대해
아는 게 별로 없으니까 단순화하기 어려워요.
하지만 기억하세요. 정말로 알아야 할 건
측정 결과가 전부 0인지 아닌지뿐이에요.
그게 문제에 대한 우리 답을 결정하니까요.
모든 측정 결과가 0이면
함수가 상수라고 결론 내려요.
측정 결과 중 어느 하나라도 1이면
함수가 균형 잡혀 있다고 결론 내려요.
그러면 측정에서 전부 0인 문자열을
얻을 확률을 계산해 볼게요.
그리고 그게 실제로 계산하기 쉬운 유일한 결과예요.
전부 0인 문자열의 이진 내적은
어떤 문자열과도 0이니까요. 벡터를 살펴보고
y가 전부 0인 문자열일 때 어떻게 되는지 생각하면,
측정에서 전부 0인 문자열을 얻을
확률에 대해 여기 이 식을 얻어요.
f가 상수인 경우와 f가 균형 잡힌 경우의 두 가지를 고려하면,
전부 0인 문자열을 얻을 확률은
f가 상수일 때 1이고, f가 균형 잡혀 있을 때 0이에요.
f가 상수이면, 합은 2의 n승 또는 -2의 n승이고,
2의 n승으로 나누고
절대값의 제곱을 취하면
1이 돼요.
f가 균형 잡혀 있으면, 합은 0이에요.
+1과 -1이 같은 횟수로 나타나서
전부 상쇄되기 때문이에요.
그래서 그게 전부예요. Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘은
단일 쿼리로 Deutsch-Jozsa 문제를 풀어요.
그리고 오류가 없어요. 연산이 모두 완벽하게
수행된다면, 매번 정확해요.
그러면 고전적으로 할 수 있는 것과
어떻게 비교될까요?
매번 정확한 답을 내는 결정론적
알고리즘을 고집한다면, 최악의 경우
2의 n승 빼기 1 더하기 1번의 쿼리가 필요해요.
함수를 입력의 절반 이상에 대해
쿼리해야 답을 확신할 수 있으니까요.
2의 n승 빼기 1개의 서로 다른 입력 문자열에 대해
함수를 쿼리해도, 매번 같은 출력 값을
볼 가능성이 있어요. 함수가 상수이기 때문일 수도 있고,
실제로는 균형 잡혀 있는데
매번 같은 출력 값만 봤을 만큼
엄청나게 운이 나빴을 수도 있어요.
그래서 양자가 고전적인 것에 비해 엄청난 이점이에요.
단일 쿼리 대 지수적으로 많은 쿼리니까요.
하지만 확률적 쿼리 알고리즘을 사용하고
잘못된 답을 낼 작은 확률을 받아들인다면,
실제로 몇 번의 쿼리만 필요해요.
특히 무작위로 k개의 문자열을 선택하고
그 무작위 문자열에 대해 함수를 평가하면,
올바른 답을 알아낼 수 있을 가능성이 꽤 높아요.
구체적으로, 매번 같은 함수 값을 얻으면
0 또는 상수라고 답하고, 두 가지 다른 함수 값을 보면
1 또는 균형 잡혀 있다고
답해요.
그렇게 하면 함수가 상수일 때는 항상 맞아요.
이 경우에는 물론 항상 같은 출력 값을 보니까요.
그리고 f가 균형 잡혀 있으면
두 가지 다른 출력 값을 볼 가능성이 매우 높아요.
이 경우에 두 출력 값을 모두 보지 못할 확률은
동전을 k번 던져서
매번 같은 결과를
얻을 확률과 같아요.
예를 들어 k를 11로 설정하면,
틀린 답을 얻을 확률은 0.1퍼센트 미만이에요.
특히 현실에서 양자 컴퓨터가 완벽할 수 없다는 걸 고려하면,
여기서 실제로 그렇게 큰 이점을 얻는 건 아니지만,
진전을 이루고 있고, Deutsch의 알고리즘을 넘어서는 양자 대 고전적의 정량화 가능한 이점이 있어요.
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit을 사용해서 Bernstein-Vazirani 문제로 알려진 다른 쿼리 문제도 풀 수 있어요.
여기 그 문제의 진술이에요. 입력은 n비트에서
1비트로의 함수로, Deutsch-Jozsa 문제와 같은데,
그리고 다시, 이건 프로미스 문제예요.
이번에 프로미스는 어떤 n비트 문자열 s가 존재해서
함수 f가 여기 보이는 것처럼 작동한다는 거예요.
출력이 입력과 이 문자열 s의
이진 내적으로 주어지는 거예요.
목표는 단순히 문자열 s를 찾는 거예요.
문자열 s가 어떤 의미에서 숨겨져 있다고 상상할 수 있는데,
f에 쿼리를 해서 그것에 대해 배울 수 있고,
목표는 이 숨겨진 문자열을 찾는 거예요.
분명히 하면, 대부분의 함수는 이 프로미스를
만족하지 않지만, 늘 그렇듯 프로미스를 만족하는 입력 함수에만 관심이 있어요.
알고 보면, Deutsch-Jozsa circuit이 실제로
이 문제를 바로 풀어요.
어떤 문자열 s에 대해 프로미스를 만족하는
이런 함수에 대해 실행하면, 측정이 문자열 s를 드러내요.
후처리가 필요 없이요.
어떻게 작동하는지 볼게요.
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit을 이미 분석했으니까
바로 끝으로 건너뛸 수 있어요.
측정 직전의 상태에 대해 이전에 얻었던 식이 여기 있고,
그 식은 어떤 함수 f에 대해서도 유효했어요.
이제 함수 f에 대해 보장된 것을
대입하고 단순화하면,
아래쪽 qubit에 대해 마이너스 상태를 얻고
위쪽 n개 qubit에 대해 ket s를 텐서 곱한 거예요.
그래서 측정하면 s를 얻어요.
여기서 보여준 단순화를 수행하려면 좀 해야 할 일이 있는데,
이 영상에서는 그걸 다 거치지 않을 거예요.
하지만 이 시리즈의 교재 내용에 더 자세한 내용이 있고, 영상 설명에 있는 링크를 따라가면 찾을 수 있어요.
아니면 연습 삼아
직접 해 보세요.
그래서 우리가 발견한 건, Deutsch-Jozsa circuit이
단일 쿼리로 Bernstein-Vazirani 문제를 푼다는 거예요.
결정론적이든 확률적이든 어떤 고전적 알고리즘이든
최소 n번의 쿼리가 필요하다는 걸 보여주는 건 그리 어렵지 않아요.
Bernstein-Vazirani 문제를 풀려면요. 간단한 이유는
s를 복구하려면 n비트의 정보가 필요하고,
각 쿼리는 최대 1비트의
정보를 주니까요.
그래서 양자 대 고전적 쿼리 알고리즘의 또 다른 이점이에요.
양자 알고리즘은 한 번의 쿼리,
고전적 알고리즘은 n번의 쿼리요.
이 문제의 맥락에서 사용되는 명칭과
역사에 대해 잠시 이야기하는 게 좋을 것 같아요.
사람들이 방금 설명한 알고리즘을 Bernstein-Vazirani 알고리즘이라고 부르기도 하는데,
사실 그냥 Deutsch-Jozsa circuit이에요.
그건 실제로 Bernstein과 Vazirani의
연구에서 매우 명확하게 진술된 거예요.
그래서 Bernstein-Vazirani 알고리즘이라고 불리는 게 좀 이상해요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘과 거의 같은 건데
후처리만 빠진 거니까요. 하지만 Bernstein과 Vazirani는
한 걸음 더 나아갔어요.
이 문제의 재귀적 버전을 정의했는데,
기본적으로 Bernstein-Vazirani 문제의 인스턴스를 풀어서
복잡한 트리 같은 패턴으로 배열된
새로운 인스턴스를 열어야 하는 거예요.
매우 인위적인 문제이지만, 핵심은 이런 식으로 문제를 정의함으로써
효과적으로 늘릴 수 있었다는 거예요.
양자와 고전적 사이의 1 대 n 쿼리 분리를요.
그리고 그들이 얻은 건, 확률적 알고리즘 대비 양자의
소위 초다항식 이점의 최초의 알려진 예예요.
이 재귀적 버전의 Bernstein-Vazirani 문제는
훨씬 후에 계산 복잡도 이론에서도
다른 이유로 매우 흥미로운 것으로 밝혀졌어요.
어쨌든, 핵심은 Bernstein과 Vazirani가 그들의 중요한
기여에 대해 인정받을 자격이 확실히 있다는 거예요.
하지만 이걸 Bernstein-Vazirani 알고리즘이라고 부르는 건
정말 말이 안 돼요. 기본적으로 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘이니까요.
레슨의 마지막 부분에서는 Simon의 알고리즘으로 알려진
양자 쿼리 알고리즘을 하나 더 살펴볼 거예요.
이 알고리즘과 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘 사이에 분명한 유사점이 보일 거예요.
하지만 다르고, 더 중요한 건
고전적 쿼리 알고리즘에 비해 양자의 훨씬 더 강한
이점을 보여준다는 거예요.
구체적으로, 확률적 알고리즘을 포함해서
고전적 알고리즘 대비 양자의 증명 가능한 지수적 이점을 제공해요.
풀리는 문제는 약간 인위적이고, 이 문제를 푸는 게
유용한 상황을 상상하기 어렵지만,
Peter Shor가 정수 인수분해를 위한
양자 알고리즘을 발견하는 데 직접적으로 영감을 줬어요.
그리고 이건 양자 알고리즘적 아이디어가 개발될 수 있는
페트리 접시로서의 쿼리 모델이라는 아이디어를 매우 강하게 뒷받침해요.
Simon의 알고리즘이 푸는 쿼리 문제부터 시작해 볼게요.
짐작했을 수도 있듯이, Simon의 문제라고 불려요.
여기 문제의 진술이 있고, 이게 무엇에 관한 건지 이해하려면 풀어봐야 해요.
먼저 주목할 건 이번에는 입력 함수 f가
n비트 문자열을 m비트 문자열로 매핑한다는 거예요.
여기서 m은 일반적으로 1이 아닌 어떤 양의 정수예요.
프로미스 문제예요. Bernstein-Vazirani 문제처럼 프로미스는 숨겨진 문자열로 볼 수 있는 어떤 문자열 s를 포함하고,
역시 Bernstein-Vazirani 문제처럼
목표는 이 숨겨진 문자열 s를 출력하는 거예요.
이번에는 프로미스가 더 복잡하니까
분해해서 뭘 말하는지 이해해 볼게요.
먼저 읽어 볼게요. 길이가 n인 문자열 s가 존재해서
n비트 문자열 x와 y의 모든 선택에 대해
특정 "필요충분" 조건이 참이라고 해요.
구체적으로, f(x)가 f(y)와 같을 필요충분조건이
두 가지 가능성 중 하나가 성립하는 것이어야 해요.
첫 번째 가능성은 x가 y와 같은 거고,
두 번째 가능성은 x의 비트별 배타적 OR을
숨겨진 문자열 s와 취하면 Y를 얻는 거예요.
이건 대부분의 함수가 만족하지 않는다는 점에서
꽤 엄격한 프로미스예요.
아주 특별한 함수만
이 조건을 만족해요.
이 프로미스와 따라서 문제 자체를 더 잘 이해하기 위해, 두 가지 주요 경우를 고려할 거예요.
첫 번째 경우는 s가
전부 0인 문자열인 거예요.
이 경우, 프로미스의 "필요충분" 진술을
단순화할 수 있어요. 어떤 문자열 x의 비트별 배타적 OR을
전부 0인 문자열과 취하면
단순히 문자열 x이니까요.
그래서 조건은 f(x)가 f(y)와 같을 필요충분조건이
x가 y와 같은 것으로 단순화돼요.
그건 f가 일대일 함수라고 말하는 다른 방법일 뿐이에요.
다시 말해서, 가능한 각 문자열 x에 대해
문자열 f(x)가 유일해야 해요.
그래서 f가 일대일 함수이면, 프로미스가 실제로 만족돼요.
구체적으로 s가 전부 0인 문자열일 때요.
그리고 이 경우, 그게
정확한 출력이에요.
두 번째 경우는 s가 전부 0인 문자열이 아닌 거고,
이것이 의미하는 건 함수 f가 이대일이어야 한다는 거예요.
그래서 모든 입력 문자열 x에 대해, f가 x가 매핑되는 것과
같은 문자열로 매핑하는 정확히 하나의 다른 문자열이 있고,
더 나아가 그 다른 문자열은 x와 s의
비트별 배타적 OR을 취해서 얻는 문자열이어야 해요.
이걸 달리 말하면, 모든 n비트 문자열 x에
파트너가 있고, 그 파트너는
s와 비트별 배타적 OR을 취해서 얻는 문자열이에요.
두 파트너를 f에 넣으면 같은 출력 문자열을 줘야 하고,
다른 문자열은 같은 출력 문자열을 줘서는 안 돼요.
그래서 파트너들이 만들어내는 건 반드시 구별되는 문자열이에요.
여기 값의 표로 설명된 이런 함수의 예가 있어요.
이건 3비트에서 5비트로의
함수예요.
이 값의 표를 한참 들여다보면,
프로미스가 문자열 011에 대해 만족된다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
000과 011은 파트너예요. 둘 중 하나를
s로 XOR하면 나머지를 얻고,
같은 출력 값을 가져요. 이 경우에는 10011이고,
다른 문자열은 같은 출력 문자열을 만들지 않아요.
001과 010은 파트너예요. 둘 중 하나를
s로 XOR하면 나머지를 얻고, 같은 출력 값을 만들어요.
역시 다른 문자열은
만들어내지 않는 출력이에요.
그리고 100과 111 그리고
101과 110도 비슷한 상황이에요.
그래서 이 함수가 문제의 입력이면,
정답은 문자열 011이에요.
전에 말했듯이, 대부분의 함수는 이 프로미스를 만족하지 않아요. 매우 특정한 조건이에요.
또한 프로미스가 만족되면,
오직 하나의 문자열 s에 대해서만 만족될 수 있다는 것도 주목해야 해요.
그래서 이 문제에 대한 정답은
항상 하나뿐이에요.
그래서 이게 Simon의 문제예요. 말했듯이, 이 문제를 풀고 싶은 실용적인 상황을 상상하기 어렵지만,
그게 포인트가 아니에요. 포인트는 양자 컴퓨터가 뭘 잘하는지 알아내는 거고, 이 특정 문제를 푸는 데 고전적 알고리즘보다
훨씬 뛰어나다는 게 밝혀져요.
이제 Simon의 문제를 푸는
Simon의 알고리즘을 살펴볼게요.
알고리즘은 여기 보이는 양자 circuit을
여러 번 실행한 다음, 고전적 후처리 단계로 구성돼요.
여러 번이 정확히 뭘 의미하는지는
나중에 더 구체적으로 말할 거예요.
circuit은 Deutsch-Jozsa circuit과 매우 비슷해 보여요.
이번에는 함수 f가 n비트를 m비트로 매핑하니까,
query gate가 달라요. 아래쪽에 qubit 하나만 있는 대신
이제 아래쪽에 m개의 qubit이 있고
위쪽에는 이전처럼 n개가 있어요.
핵심 차이점은 아래쪽에 마이너스 상태나
여러 마이너스 상태를 설정하지 않는다는 거예요.
이 아래쪽 qubit들은 모두 0 상태로 초기화되고,
그 상태가 바로 query gate에 들어가요.
그래서 이 알고리즘에는 위상 킥백이 관여하지 않아요. 이건 그렇게 작동하지 않아요.
방금 언급한 차이점들 외에는
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit과 매우 비슷해 보여요.
Hadamard gate 층을 적용하고, query gate를 한 번 적용하고,
그 다음 또 다른 Hadamard gate 층을 적용해요.
그 뒤에 위쪽 n개 qubit의 표준 기저 측정이 따라와요.
아이디어는 이 circuit을 실행하고 측정할 때마다
Simon의 문제에서 숨겨진 문자열 s에 대해
뭔가를 알려주는 문자열 y를 얻는다는 거예요.
circuit을 독립적으로 여러 번 실행하면 s에 대한
충분한 통계적 증거를 모아서
높은 확신으로 알아낼 수 있어요.
이제 Simon의 알고리즘의 양자 circuit을
분석해서 뭘 하는지 볼게요.
첫 번째 Hadamard gate 층 이후의 상태는
이렇게 생겼어요. Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘에서와 비슷해요.
이번에는 아래쪽 m개 qubit이 마이너스 상태가 아니라
모두 0 상태라는 점만 다르고요.
query gate가 수행된 후, f(x) 값이
아래쪽 또는 가장 왼쪽 m개 qubit에 기록된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
f(x)가 전부 0인 문자열에 XOR됐기 때문이에요.
그래서 다시 말하지만, 이 알고리즘에서는 위상 킥백이 일어나지 않아요.
그런 다음 두 번째
Hadamard gate 층을 수행해요.
표준 기저 상태, 이 경우 ket x에 대한
Hadamard gate 층의 작용에 대해 이전과 같은 공식을 사용하면,
원래 공식에서처럼, 여기 이 상태를 얻어요.
Hadamard gate의 작용이
더 명확하게 보이게 됐어요. 하지만 원한다면
여기 있는 것처럼 더 간결한 형태로 상태를 쓸 수도 있어요.
이 시점에서 위쪽 n개 qubit을 측정해서 어떤 n비트 문자열 y를 얻는데,
서로 다른 문자열에 대한 확률이 얼마인지 알아내야 해요.
그게 이 문자열 y에서 함수 f 안에 숨겨진
문자열 s에 대해 어떤 정보를 얻는지 이해하는 데 도움이 될 거예요.
함수 f 안에 숨겨진 문자열 s에 대해서요.
이걸 위해 더 많은 공간이 필요하고,
circuit 다이어그램은 더 이상 필요 없으니까
없애고 분석을 위한 공간을 더 만들어 볼게요.
여기 측정 직전의 상태가 있는데,
위쪽 또는 가장 오른쪽 n개 qubit의 표준 기저 측정이에요.
그래서 측정은
두 번째 ket에 해당해요.
p(y)를 각 가능한 y에 대해 측정이 문자열 y를 줄 확률이라고 표기할게요.
레슨 2의 규칙을 따르면, 각 확률은 양자 상태 벡터에서
y에 해당하는 표준 기저 상태에 텐서 곱된 벡터의 유클리드 노름 제곱이에요.
우리 양자 상태 벡터에서
y에 해당하는 거예요.
그러면 여기 이 식을 얻어요.
이 확률들을 더 잘 다루기 위해
표기법을 좀 사용해야 하는데,
이미 이 표기법에 익숙할 수도 있어요.
수학에서 꽤 흔한 거니까요.
먼저, 함수 f의 치역이라고 하면,
이 함수에서 나올 수 있는 모든 문자열의 집합을 의미해요.
가능한 모든 입력 문자열 x에 대해
f(x)를 모은 집합이에요.
둘째, 여기 보이는 이 표기법을 사용할 건데,
f가 주어진 문자열 z로 매핑하는 모든 입력 문자열 x의 집합을 의미해요.
우리가 고려하고 싶은 z의 어떤 선택에 대해서든요.
함수 f의 역함수처럼 보이지만,
f가 반드시 역이 존재하는 건 아니니까 역함수가 아니에요.
왼쪽에 집합이 인자로 있다는 것도 보이는데,
이 경우에는 단일 문자열 z만 포함하는 집합이에요.
그게 함수 f의 역에 대해 이야기하는 게 아니라는 걸
알아차리는 데 필요한 단서예요. 이건 역상이라고 불려요.
역상은 인자로 주어진 어떤 집합에 대해서도
더 일반적으로 정의될 수 있어요. 단일 원소를 포함하는 집합만이 아니라요.
하지만 이게 우리에게 필요한 전부예요.
역함수와 혼동하기 쉬워서 세상에서 최고의 표기법은 아니지만,
충분히 명확하고 널리 사용되니까
이걸 쓸 거예요.
이제 이 표기법을 사용하면, 각 문자열 y를 측정할 확률을 얻기 위해
유클리드 노름 제곱을 취하는 벡터를 다시 쓸 수 있어요.
이렇게 하는 이유는 각 개별 표준 기저 상태에 대한
계수가 뭔지 봐야 하는데, 이 식에서는 그게 명확하지 않기 때문이에요.
일반적으로 같은 문자열 f(x)를 주는
x의 선택이 여러 개 있을 수 있으니까요.
본질적으로 하는 건 x에 대한 합을 분리하는 거예요.
먼저 f의 치역에 있는 모든 z에 대해 합하고,
그 합 안에서 z의 역상에 있는 모든 x에 대해 합해요.
더 정확히 말하면,
문자열 z를 포함하는 집합의
역상이에요.
그러면 여기 ket 안에서 f(x)를 z로 대체할 수 있어요.
그리고 f가 각 z로 매핑하는 서로 다른 문자열 x에 대한 합이
각 ket의 계수로 모여요.
기본적으로 문자열을 빈에 넣고, 빈에 대해 합하고,
각 빈의 문자열에 대해 합하는 거예요.
하지만 그건 모든 문자열에 대해
합하는 것과 동일해요.
그래서 시작했던 것과 동일한 식을
얻게 돼요.
이제 유클리드 노름의
제곱을 계산할 수 있어요.
그건 계수들의 절대값 제곱의 합일 뿐이고,
그래서 여기 이 식을 얻어요.
확률에 대한 거예요.
물론 이걸 검증하고 싶다면 시간을 들이세요.
이 모든 것에 익숙해지고
이런 계산을 수행할 수 있으려면
시간이 걸리고, 연습할수록 더 쉬워질 거예요.
지금까지 사실 Simon의 문제의
프로미스를 전혀 사용하지 않았어요.
이 확률에 대한 분석은 실제로 어떤 함수 f에 대해서도 작동하지만,
이제 Simon의 문제를 구체적으로 생각해 볼 때예요.
이전에 했던 것과 같은 두 가지 경우로
나눠 볼 거예요.
첫 번째 경우는 s가 전부 0인 문자열인 거고,
두 번째 경우는 s가 전부 0인 문자열이 아닌 거예요.
첫 번째 경우, s가 전부 0인
문자열인 경우는 꽤 간단해요.
이 경우에는 전에 봤듯이 f가 일대일 함수이니까,
f의 치역에 있는 각 문자열 z로
매핑되는 문자열 x가 하나뿐이에요.
그러면 그 문자열들에 대한 합의 절대값 제곱은 1이에요.
합에 항이 하나뿐이니까,
+1이든 -1이든, 절대값 제곱을 취하니까
어느 쪽이든 상관없이 1을 얻어요.
f의 치역에 2의 n승개의 원소가 있고,
f가 일대일이니까 그런 거예요. 각 입력 문자열에 대해
치역에 하나의 문자열이 있으니까요.
전체 식을 평가하면, 각 문자열 y가
2의 n승분의 1의 확률로 나타나는 걸 알 수 있어요.
다시 말해서, 측정이 균일하게
무작위로 선택된 문자열 y를 줘요.
그게 그다지 유용해 보이지 않을 수 있지만, 사실 이 동작을
s가 전부 0인 문자열이 아닌 경우에 얻는 동작과
구별할 수 있을 거예요. 그게 어떻게 되는지 곧 볼 거예요.
하지만 지금은 단순히 관찰해요. f가 s가 전부 0인 문자열인
경우에 Simon의 문제의 프로미스를 만족하면,
측정의 결과는 균일한 무작위 문자열이에요.
이제 두 번째 경우로 넘어가요. 프로미스가
전부 0인 문자열이 아닌 문자열 s에 대해 만족되는 경우예요.
이 경우에는 전에 논의했듯이, f의 치역에 있는 각 문자열 z로 매핑되는 문자열이 정확히 두 개 있어요.
모든 문자열에 파트너가 있고, 각 파트너 쌍은
어떤 유일한 문자열로 매핑되니까요. 구체적으로 각 문자열의 파트너는
s와 XOR해서 얻는 문자열이에요.
그래서 f의 치역에서 아무 문자열 z를 골라서,
f가 z로 매핑하는 문자열 중 하나를 w라고 이름 붙이면,
w와 s의 XOR이 z로 매핑되는
다른 문자열이에요.
합에서 우리가 생각하고 있는 치역의 문자열 z에 해당하는 한 항만 보면,
여기 있는 것처럼
더 명시적으로 쓸 수 있어요.
z의 역상에 두 문자열이 있어요. w와 w XOR s.
그래서 합을 화면에서 보이는 것처럼 쓸 수 있고,
이제 할 수 있는 건 (-1)의 w 점 y승을 밖으로 빼내는 거예요.
그 인수는 +1이든 -1이든이니까
절대값을 취하면 사라지고,
남는 건 여기 이
식이에요.
세부 사항이 다 보이지는 않고, 이렇게 되는 게
반드시 명백하지는 않지만, 이 두 식이 같다는 걸
이진 내적의 정의로 돌아가서 이것들이
-1의 지수에 있을 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지 생각해 보면 확인할 수 있어요.
Bernstein-Vazirani 문제에서
봤던 것과 비슷해요.
마지막으로 이 식을
두 가지 경우로 나눌 수 있어요.
s와 y의 이진 내적이 0이면 4이고,
s와 y의 이진 내적이 1이면 0이에요.
특히 주목할 건 여기서 w나 z에 대한
의존성이 전혀 없다는 거예요. s와 y에만 의존해요.
이것이 일어나는 이유는 프로미스의
매우 구체적이고 특별한 성질 때문이에요.
본질적으로, 이게 프로미스가 이런 식으로 공식화된 이유예요. 이 모든 게 이렇게 맞아떨어지도록요.
다시 한번, 모든 문자열에 파트너가 있는데,
이 하나의 숨겨진 문자열 s와 XOR해서 얻는 거고,
그게 이 모든 걸 가능하게 하는 거예요.
이제 확률에 대한 식으로 돌아가서
값을 대입할 수 있어요.
s가 전부 0인 문자열이 아닐 때, f의 치역에
2의 n-1승개의 원소가 있는데,
입력 문자열 수의 절반이에요.
방금 계산한 값을 대입하면 여기 이 공식을 얻어요.
그래서 이번에는 y가 완전히 무작위인 문자열이 아니라,
n비트 문자열의 정확히 절반에 대해 균일하게 분포해요.
구체적으로, s와 이진 내적이
0인 문자열들에 대해 균일하게 분포해요.
이제 Simon의 알고리즘의 circuit이 어떻게 작동하는지,
구체적으로 서로 다른 측정 결과에 대한 확률이 뭔지 아니까,
이것이 Simon의 문제를 푸는 데 어떻게 도움이 되는지 설명하는 것만 남았어요.
방금 배운 것을 요약하면, 함수 f가 Simon의 문제에서 프로미스를 만족하는 경우,
숨겨진 문자열 s가 전부 0인 문자열일 때,
측정에서 완전히 무작위인 문자열을 얻고,
각 n비트 문자열 y가
동일한 확률이에요.
반면에 함수 f가 전부 0인 문자열이 아닌
다른 문자열 s에 대해 프로미스를 만족하면,
s와 이진 내적이 0인 무작위 문자열 y를 얻고,
그런 문자열들 중에서 각 y가 동일한 확률이에요.
하지만 s와 이진 내적이 1인
문자열 y는 절대 얻지 못해요.
질문은 "이 정보가 s를 결정하기에 충분한가?"이고,
이미 시사했듯이 답은 네예요.
circuit을 충분한 횟수만큼
실행한다면요.
구체적으로, circuit을 k번 실행한다고 가정할게요.
K는 n 더하기 r이고,
r은 s를 복구할 가능성을
제어하는 어떤 수예요.
예를 들어 r을 10으로 선택하면
99.9% 이상의 확률로 성공할 거예요.
그래서 r이 그렇게 클 필요는 없어요.
일반적으로, 실패 확률은 공정한 동전을
r번 던져서 매번 앞면이 나올 확률보다 작아요.
99.9%가 충분하지 않다면 r을 20으로 잡으면 되고,
실패 확률은 백만분의 1 미만이에요.
아니면 편한 r을 선택하세요.
올바른 해를 보장할 수는 없지만, 오류 확률을
무시할 수 있을 정도로 작게 만들 수 있어요.
모든 실질적인 목적에서요.
여기서 이 문자열들을 y1부터 yk까지로 이름 짓고 있는데,
위첨자를 사용해서 이름을 짓는 거예요.
그래야 아래첨자를 그 문자열들의
개별 비트를 가리키는 데 쓸 수 있으니까요.
이건 거듭제곱이나 그런 게 아니에요.
이 k개의 문자열에 붙이는 이름일 뿐이에요.
각각의 길이는 n이에요. Simon의 알고리즘의
circuit을 실행해서 얻었으니까요.
그래서 이 k개 문자열의 개별 비트를
여기 보이는 것처럼 쓸 수 있어요.
이제 하는 건 행렬 m을 만드는 거예요. 이 행렬의 각 항목은 비트이고,
이 비트들은 방금 측정한 문자열에서 가져와요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요.
이 행렬은 k개의 행과 n개의 열을 가지고, 항목은 모두 이진 값이에요.
우리는 s가 뭔지 몰라요. 그걸 찾으려는 거니까요.
하지만 잠시 s를 안다고 상상해 보고,
여기 보이는 것처럼 s의 비트로
열 벡터를 만들었다고 해요.
그 벡터에 m을 곱하고 결과를 모듈로 2로 취하면, 다시 말해서
덧셈을 배타적 OR로 대체하면,
반드시 전부 0인 벡터를 얻게 돼요.
이 결과 벡터의 각 항목이 다름 아닌
s와 m의 행 중 하나의
이진 내적이기 때문이에요.
S가 전부 0인 문자열이면, 이진 내적에서 항상 0 벡터를 얻어요.
s가 전부 0인 문자열이 아니면,
문자열 y1부터 yk가 나타날 확률에 대해 아는 것에서 이걸 얻어요.
특히 s와의 이진 내적이
이 모든 문자열에 대해 항상 0이에요.
간단히 말하면, s의 비트로 만든 이 벡터가
항상 행렬 m의 영공간에 있다는 거예요.
모든 산술을 모듈로 2로 한다고 가정하면요.
하지만 물론 s가 뭔지 모르니까,
s를 찾으려는 거예요.
하지만 할 수 있는 건, 이 행렬 m의
영공간을 모듈로 2로 계산하는 거예요.
구체적으로, 가우스 소거법이라는 기법을 사용해서
할 수 있는데, 보통 입문 선형대수 수업에서
가르치는 절차예요.
모든 산술을 모듈로 2로 해도 완벽하게 잘 작동하고,
컴퓨터로 꽤 효율적으로 할 수 있어요.
m의 영공간을 계산하면, 이 k개의 문자열이 무작위로 선택된
구체적인 방식에 의해,
1 빼기 2의 -r승보다 큰 확률로
s를 복구할 수 있어요.
구체적으로, 1 빼기 2의 -r승보다 큰 확률로 볼 수 있는 건,
영공간이 전부 0인 벡터를 포함하고,
모든 행렬에 대해 항상 그렇듯이, s에 해당하는 벡터도 포함한다는 거예요. 전부 0인 벡터이든 아니든요.
그리고 가장 중요한 건, 다른 벡터는
영공간에 나타나지 않는다는 거예요.
이걸 증명하는 건 사실 그렇게 어렵지 않지만, 자세히 다루지는 않을 거예요.
아이디어는 전부 0인 벡터도 아니고
s도 아닌 다른 문자열이 있으면, 무작위 문자열
y1부터 yk 각각이
기본적으로 1/2의 확률로
그걸 영공간에서 제거할 거라는 거예요.
그래서 k번 실행 후에는 살아남을
가능성이 전혀 없고, 사실 속하지 않는
문자열 중 어느 것도 살아남을 가능성이 없어요.
확률 이론에서 유니온 바운드라고 알려진 매우 간단한 사실을 사용해서 이를 확립할 수 있어요.
여기서 모든 세부 사항을 설명하지는 않았지만,
이 행렬 m의 모듈로 2 영공간을 계산함으로써
s를 복구할 가능성이 매우 높다는 아이디어를 이해했기를 바라요.
그게 Simon의 알고리즘이 Simon의 문제를 푸는 방법이에요.
Simon의 문제에 대해 한 가지만 더 말할 게 있는데,
이 문제의 고전적 난이도에 관한 거예요.
즉, 고전적 쿼리 알고리즘이 Simon의 문제를 풀려면 몇 번의 쿼리가 필요할까요?
답은, 일반적으로 매우 많이요.
이 문제의 고전적 난이도에 대해
다양한 정확한 진술을 할 수 있는데, 여기 그중 하나예요.
어떤 확률적 쿼리 알고리즘이 있고 그 알고리즘이
2의 n/2 빼기 1승 빼기 1보다 적은 쿼리를 하면,
n에 대해 지수적인 쿼리 수인데,
그 알고리즘은 Simon의 문제를 풀지 못할 거예요.
최소 1/2의 확률로요.
때때로 이런 불가능성 결과를 증명하는 게
매우 도전적일 수 있지만, 이건 초등적인
확률적 분석을 통해
증명하기 그리 어렵지 않아요.
이 영상 레슨에서는 그걸 하지 않을 거고,
그 뒤의 직관에만 집중할게요.
숨겨진 문자열 s를 찾으려는 건데, 같은 출력 값을 가진
두 문자열에 대해 함수를 쿼리하지 않는 한,
s에 대한 정보가
매우 제한적이에요.
기본적으로 배우는 건, 숨겨진 문자열 s가
쿼리한 서로 다른 두 문자열의 배타적 OR이 아니라는 것뿐이에요.
이 쿼리 수보다 적게 함수를 쿼리하면, 배제되지 않은 s의 선택이 여전히 많이 남아 있을 거예요.
아직 배제되지 않은 거예요.
이건 형식적 증명은 아니지만
기본적인 아이디어예요.
요약하면, Simon의 알고리즘은 쿼리 모델 내에서
양자가 고전적 알고리즘에 비해 갖는 인상적인 이점을 제공해요.
특히 Simon의 알고리즘은 함수의 입력 비트 수 n에
선형적인 수의 쿼리로 Simon의 문제를 풀어요.
반면 어떤 고전적 알고리즘이든,
확률적이더라도, n에 대해 지수적인 수의 쿼리를 해야
합리적인 성공 확률로 Simon의 문제를 풀 수 있어요.
Simon의 문제가 아마 아무도 정말로 풀고 싶어하지 않는
다소 인위적인 문제인 건 맞지만,
그건 부차적이에요. 때로는 아이디어가 실제에 적용되기 전에 개발되어야 해요.
실제로 Peter Shor는 자신의 이제 유명한 양자 알고리즘에
영감을 준 게 Simon의 알고리즘이었다고 명확히 밝혔어요.
정수 인수분해를 위한 알고리즘인데, 몇 레슨 후에 볼 거예요.
이것으로 레슨 5를 마칩니다.
이 레슨에서는 쿼리 계산 모델을 살펴보고,
고전적 알고리즘에 비해 이점을 보여주는
양자 알고리즘의 일련의 예를
이 모델 안에서 봤어요.
사실 쿼리 모델과 제가 논의하지 않은
다른 문제에 대한 양자 알고리즘에 대해 훨씬 더 많이 알려져 있어요.
이 모델이 흥미롭다고 생각하면,
더 배울 게 꽤 많아요.
다음 단계는 쿼리 모델에서 벗어나서
실제로 풀기를 희망하는 종류의 문제를
더 잘 대표하는 계산 모델로 이동하는 거예요.
레슨 6에서 함께해 주시길 바라요. 양자 알고리즘을 연구하기 위한
기초를 다지는 데 주로 집중할 거예요.
그리고 거기서부터 정수 인수분해를 위한
Shor의 알고리즘을 포함한 특정 양자 알고리즘으로
이후 레슨에서 넘어갈 거예요. 그때까지 안녕히!